even in the more affluent parts of the
country the energy price spike is
beginning to hurt average energy bills
will rise more than three and a half
thousand pounds a year in a little over
a month and the chancellor has warned
those on middle incomes of around forty
five thousand pounds a year are likely
to find it hard to pay their bills they
could need government help
hannah is a solicitor in well-heeled
dude south london but the cost of energy
is a major worry normally money that i
would put away every month to try and
save to buy a house it's going to have
to go straight out
so yeah there's nothing left at the end
of the month basically
according to research at the university
of york much of the country could
struggle to keep warm this winter
because of rising energy costs estimates
given to sky news suggest almost 80
percent of the population will be in
fuel poverty by january
pensioners and families with three
children will be particularly badly hit
with 90 percent in fuel poverty
in all more than 50 million people will
be affected
more than 50 of all household types are
going to be um
suffering uh as a result of
um
this price
hike
and uh
they're particularly going to be
suffering in the winter months
many businesses are struggling too there
is no energy price cap for them
and at the cherry tree inn in
oxfordshire the electricity bill alone
has risen from just over a thousand a
month to six and a half thousand
dan the landlord fears he'll have to lay
off two-thirds of his staff unless the
government cuts that or business rates
so many factors uh linked into the cost
of living crisis but we're going into
the winter a time when um you know the
heating comes back on
um and the fire needs to be lit every
single thing that um we pay for now is
more expensive so just to open the doors
it's triple the cost
you know in an already decimated
industry hit badly by covid and brexit
um
it's going to be a really bleak winter
for this industry
the eye-watering cost of energy has gone
far beyond just affecting people on the
benefits it's going to hit people who
had thought their finances were secure
the chancellor has called it a national
emergency and warned it could last for
up to two years
the treasury has said is looking at all
options to help households both
candidates to be the next prime minister
have pledged more support but have given
no details
thomas more sky news